if you have rodents in a cage and you
change their diet so they're still
allowed to eat as much as they want but
you change their regular Chow with a
cafeteria diet muffins biscuits cakes
Etc they gain weight reliably and you
don't blame the rat you've changed their
food and the rat is suddenly wanting to
eat more because the foods are delicious
that's what's happening to us on a human
level I view it as people trying to diet
now probably feel like they're swimming
Upstream more than they would have 30
years ago when it would be easier to
stay leaner
I came up with an idea this morning that
I've been thinking about for a little
while quote from Mark Manson that says
identity likes Reality by one to two
years there's a lot of psychological
Fallout from a rapid change in status
they needed a name for it the name that
I came up to was having a look through
your book earlier on today is identity
dysmorphia
okay my thinking yeah my thinking behind
this is that whether it's with fat loss
whether it's with a glow up or a glow
down uh or a change in the job role that
you've got or your status on social
media or if you get plucked out of
obscurity and put on love Island
people's identity their understanding of
their identity does seem to lag behind a
little bit and I think that the same
must be true in terms of our body image
who we see ourselves as I mean there's
even memes and jokes about guys that go
to the gym to try and sort of hit on
girls that are uh in the process of
getting into shape in the hopes that
they can sort of buy Bitcoin at five
cents what do you what do you think
about identity dysmorphia
um to be honest I'm actually kind of
intrigued to hear where you were going
with that I'm not used to hearing a host
golf on such an interesting monologue to
begin with what can I say oh all I was
thinking was that um given that we're
going to be talking a lot about fat loss
today
someone's body image how they see
themselves probably largely determines
their enjoyment of their health and
fitness regime and drives their changes
and what they want to do moving forward
as well
so you posted a video I think yesterday
or the day before depending on uh social
media's post timing so you said you were
talking about Mr Olympia and you said if
you compete in Mr Olympia regardless of
how your physique looks depending on the
date that you compete you may be second
in the world you may be third in the
world and why it's important not to have
those kind of external yardsticks as the
things that are judging your progress
because you're not in control of all the
external yardsticks and I think that's
kind of an interesting parallel to Fat
Loss advice or muscle building advice in
general because a lot of people go into
say a fat loss Journey or a muscle
building Journey
using these as kind of proxy goals for
health and happiness if I lose fat I
will be healthier which is not always
necessarily true or if I build muscle I
will be more confident I will be more
attractive to the opposite sex I will my
life will become complete which again
isn't always true and the way I like to
view it is
take muscle building for example if you
say I'm going to be happy when I build
muscle
a lot of people will attest that it's
just not that straightforward they build
muscle but they become more critical of
how they look body dysmorphia muscle
dysmorphia especially in men and it can
almost be this kind of spiral where
people think oh if I gain a few pounds
of muscle if I get slightly bigger arms
I'll be happier and then they gain a few
pounds of muscle they get slightly
bigger arms but then they want slightly
bigger shoulders and they want slightly
bigger arms again then they want a more
chiseled six-pack and it can sometimes
if if you're not careful it can
sometimes be a kind of spiral towards
body dissatisfaction because you're
putting too much emphasis on how you
look that kind of self-objectification
on how you look in the mirror and how
other people perceive you and you can
chase that proxy goal of muscle growth
so
steadfastly that you can inadvertently
sacrifice your mental health elsewhere
what is the antidote to that
I don't know it's a great question it's
a great question so one of the things as
a kind of an anecdote of something that
I personally say my personal Journey
research on this is kind of difficult
because you can do surveys and you can
ask people how they feel about their
body and whether they weight train and
you can identify Trends you can identify
associations and discrepancies and you
can say for example oh bodybuilders who
compete often have higher levels or body
dissatisfaction
but what you don't necessarily get are
randomized control trials identifying
how you fix that you can't say one group
of bodybuilders did this and it helped
another group of bodybuilders did this
and it didn't help
so some of the things that I personally
think are good to consider for example
let's say me and you both started weight
training we did exactly the same regime
we did followed exactly the same
nutrition plan
but there are behaviors that you do or I
do that the other one doesn't
some of them that I suspect could cause
issues are things like
um
self monitoring so for example
um how often you weigh yourself how
often you test your body fat how often
you look in the mirror can be another
one
um
you call it body surveillance people
that tend to look in the mirror a lot to
monitor their physique tend to have
lower levels of body satisfaction which
is again seen in bodybuilders and
competitive bodybuilders more so than
your average control population so
people who look in the mirror a lot to
monitor their physique that is not
necessarily I would say a red flag but
perhaps a least a yellow flag people
that weigh themselves obsessively or
people who track their calorie intake
obsessively these are things that can be
identified as risk factors for kind of
disordered eating and worse body image
um another one is training just to
change the way you look
so correct me if I'm wrong but you have
trained in many sports over the years
and what you may have noticed is if you
find a sport that you enjoy
even if it's a sport that can modify
your body composition doing it for the
enjoyment can change the outcome of how
you feel about your own body so if I go
to the gym and I'm lifting weights with
the sole focus of changing the way I
look I may have
um I may be more critical of my own
physique
and have that kind of
self-objectification then you would be
who's lifting weights just because you
enjoy it yeah I mean that was the the
huge red pill that I saw when I started
Crossfit because as it happens when
anybody starts to do CrossFit they go oh
my God this is so cool and it's kind of
like a cult and no one's wearing any
clothes and Friday Night Lights and I
get to PB and yeah
that drove me to train so much more than
any desire to have a six-pack ever did
and
perhaps surprisingly I ended up in the
best condition that I've ever been in
because of my compliance with training
so I was training incredibly hard
because I wanted to train because the
outcome I got from training was
something inherently enjoyable in and of
itself
Downstream from that
I got ripped
that's exactly it and that that's one of
the things that I feel really
passionately about because I kind of
went on my own journey of I'm trying to
build muscle I'm trying to probably be
more attractive to the opposite sex
probably trying to make myself less
insecure which is how I felt as a
teenager and adulthood probably but you
can do exactly the same thing you can do
the same thing with your program but by
approaching it differently you can have
very different mental health and Body
Image outcomes and I think one example
of that so one thing that I really like
about uh say a typical CrossFit Studio
or at least the ones that I've seen is
they tend to have far fewer mirrors
people who train there tend to train
hard they're often topless which is the
type of thing that you would expect puts
more pressure on you to look a certain
way but because you don't have mirrors
there's no everyone standing there
flexing between sets you're going in
there you're training hard you're doing
all the things from a workout that will
cause your body to adapt grow muscle
lose fat whatever
but I think that the mental health
outcome of that is probably different to
traditional bodybuilding gyms and I've
been to a fair few where it's very
common for people to do one set then
take their top off and stand in front of
the mirror and flex and pose from
different angles and it's that body
surveillance where you're constantly
looking at your body and also the
critique critique in your body if you're
a professional bodybuilder for example
to use a very extreme end of the
spectrum they will have often whole
training Cycles developed to bringing up
their weak points so if you ask a pro
bodybuilder what their weak points are
they will often say my medial deltoid
isn't quite as sculpted as it could be
or like my my vastus medialis isn't
quite as big as I'd like it to be in
relation to my vast as lateralis and
it's like an obsessive amount of
um
body surveillance some kind of self
objectification yeah that's scrutiny's
hard so we're going to get into talking
about fat loss today and health and
training but before we do what's your
background for the people who don't know
you what what gives you any license to
talk about the subject of fat loss so I
have been a personal trainer since I was
2006. General personal trainer working
in commercial gyms with a very diverse
range of clients
so I would have clients who came to me
who were fitness models wanting to diet
for a show I would have people like
um middle-aged Housewives who want to
lose a few pounds because they want to
feel healthier or perhaps increase their
lifespan and then I had
elderly clients who were just trying to
make themselves a bit more resilient
should they fall which was you know
literally their goal
and I worked in commercial gyms for
years this was obviously uh approaching
20 years now
um
and working with a diverse range of
clients the question that always came up
it was always fat loss fat loss was the
goal that superseded everything fat loss
is the most common goal in the fitness
industry and it's estimated that half or
around half of adults at least in
America diet at least once per year
and the more clients that saw me about
fat loss the more I researched fat loss
and it just became this spiral of me
going deeper and deep into reading
research papers so I have no
higher Academia background I was never
someone who started thinking I want to
become a PhD I was a personal trainer
who was working with people one-on-one
as my primary uh income and then behind
the scenes I was just kind of
self-described research nerd where I
have folders upon subfolders upon
subfolders of different research studies
just trying to communicate
the best objectively current most
factually correct information to social
media and my clients what would you
describe how would you classify your
approach to health and fitness like
where is it that you're coming from
for me it seems like science-based
evidence-based is that the camp that you
identify with is that who you've pinned
your colors to uh I I would say my main
goal if you will if you ask the average
person on the street to name one
scientist in the field of nutrition
weight training aerobic training
whatever most of them can't do it
because scientists are working behind
the scenes to write research papers what
I tend to do is communicate those
research papers research papers to a
bigger audience so I try and read many
many scientific papers and then simplify
them into videos that go on social media
so I kind of bridge that Gap by trying
to simplify
evidence-based information to a wider
audience yeah I mean your social media
content is some of the most digestible
easily understood it's the equivalent
for diet I think of what Derek from more
plates more dates does with a number of
the studies that he does and I imagine
that you must find at least a little bit
of affinity with the way that he goes
about things deep Dives papers
evidence-based Etc yeah so uh as an
example
um I'm I was editing a video today on
um
kind of bodybuilding contest prep and
body image and it will be a 90 second
video and I think I cite six research
papers in that it's it's a lot of effort
but it's trying to make it in a way that
it's super easily digestible for people
so when they watch it they learn
something but it's not boring it's not
dry which scientific research papers
tend to be so it's it's trying to make
science a little bit easier digestible
by making it a bit more entertaining as
well if if you can do it why is the
weight loss industry so shitty
if I can do it as in communicate things
objectively correct
uh I think there were
probably at least a bazillion reasons
for this I think one of them
one of them is always going to come down
to finances when there is an industry
that is kind of fraught with desperation
which the weight loss industry tends to
be it makes it very easy for people to
sell you something so if you look at for
example the general Trend in obesity
rates they have been going up since the
1970s so people on the whole on the
population level are gaining weight but
more people are dieting now
than they have in the past so body
weights are going up but dieting rates
are also going up and I think when you
compare those it it kind of makes you
realize that a lot of people actually
trying really hard
is not necessarily uniform lack of
willpower or laziness is that our
environment is nudging people towards
gaining weight and people feel probably
more desperate than ever to lose weight
and I think when people are more
desperate than ever it's easier to prey
on them and sell them things so for
example when if you go to Amazon top
selling diet books you will often see
completely different dietary
methodologies you will see several keto
books you will see several intermittent
fasting books you will see this diet
plan this diet plan this diet plan and
it's almost like a conveyor belt of diet
plans where people are having their best
punt at selling a book
um and that's not the solution
that's not the solution what is the
solution so
how it tends to be communicated to make
it really simple
It is believed that one of the main
drivers for OBC rates going up is the
development of the obesogenic
environment so if you went back to the
1970s
if you looked at the food selection that
was available to you you wouldn't have
the vast array of biscuits cakes muffins
crisps or chips for Americans
um that are filled in grocery stores now
and Foods tend to be cheaper tastier
hyper palatable extra tasty more
convenient because they're more shelf
stable than they used to be so it's
easier to consume more calories than it
would have been in the past when food
processing wasn't as rampant as it is
now but also there are developments in
technology that can drive sedentary
behaviors so for example
just to roll roll a few examples
together
let's say person a wakes up in the
morning they sit in that car they drive
to work they get in an elevator a lift
or an escalator they go up to a desk job
where they work for eight nine hours
then they get back on the escalator in
the lift elevator whatever go back to
their car and they drive home
and technology is advancing that acts as
labor-saving devices even in the home
dishwashers save people washing up by
hand washing machines safe people
washing up by hand electric toothbrushes
save you having to do this because you
can just hold it in your mouth even bin
Lids you can hover your hand over a bin
and the lid will come up things things
are getting easier to conserve us time
and energy and convenience and that's
making us fatter
right it's estimated that energy
expenditure the number of calories we
burn per day Trends downwards because of
these because of the advancements in
technology and modernization of the
world and when you put that along with
all of the foods that we're now
surrounded by
everywhere
think of it like this
even if you walk through a train station
there will be vending machines in the
vending machines typically I know it's
different depending on country and
depending on train station typically
will be filled with things like
chocolate bars and crisps and things
like that because they are shelf stable
they are cheap they are tasty they're
not going to perish and rot inside the
vending machine it's more convenient for
us to eat these Foods than there ever
has been and it's driving calorie
intakes up so
this
trend of body weights going up has been
described in some research papers as a
natural
body weights going up is a natural
consequence to the change in our
environment
if you viewed a different species say
for example rats
rats are easier to study for many
reasons if you have rodents in a cage
and you change their diet so they're
still allowed to eat as much as they
want they're rats you're not telling
them how much to eat but you change
their regular Chow with a cafeteria diet
muffins biscuits cakes Etc they gain
weight reliably
and you don't blame the rat you've
changed their food and the rat is
suddenly wanting to eat more because the
foods are [__] delicious
that's what's happening to us on a human
level
so I view it as people trying to diet
now probably feel like they're swimming
Upstream more than they would have 30
years ago when it would be easier to
stay Elite to stay leaner that's very
interesting and it's a much more
holistic view I think of the weight gain
epidemic problem that we've seen since
the 1970s
that I always see black and white photos
of Venice Beach in 1960 or whatever and
everyone looks like the 12 body fat even
the women and everyone's in super
healthy condition and it's used to kind
of cast aspersions on look at this
decadent modern civilization everyone's
a fat slob everybody just gets their
like Roomba to clean up after them as
they eat Cheetos laying on the couch but
the reality is that most people that are
overweight don't want to be overweight
most of the people that I know even the
guys that are in shape would like to be
in better shape and even if they're in
fantastic shape they want to improve
their health in different ways so it
very much is massively influenced I
think by the environment that we're in
the uh different types of stimulus that
we have around us I mean you you did
some studies I heard you talk about how
um the placement of different foods uh
in supermarkets and fast food places and
um default selections on food menus can
have a huge impact as well yeah so as an
example there are a few research trials
that look at things like this so it's
described as a food proximity effect if
you give people a binary choice of two
options and you have something like
apples or popcorn even though
participants will rate popcorn as a
tastier snack if you make the popcorn
sit closer to them and you place the
apples two meters away on the other end
of the table people will naturally eat
more popcorn if you flip those rounds
and the apples are close people will
just naturally eat the apples even
though they know the popcorn is tastier
because you have made it more convenient
and this can affect food purchasing
habits as well not just immediate food
selection so if you spoke to anyone
who's higher up in a supermarket and you
ask them about shelf placement they will
say that it is strategic because they
know that items placed at eye level for
example people are more inclined to buy
than item sitting at the bottom or items
that are placed near the checkout areas
easier to upsell because people are
there waiting and while they're waiting
and they've got 30 seconds they just
turn to the side and they see this
selection of chocolate bars oh yeah I'll
grab one
and these are examples of how you can
kind of subconsciously influence
people's food selection so as an example
of one of the research studies
if you take a cafeteria
and there are vending machines in the
corners there are sorry fridges in the
corners not vending machines or there's
a fridge by the checkout scanner
it was shown that if you reposition
sodas and Waters
you can get people to buy less soda
solely based off placement so they did
this as a kind of food preference thing
where they had red quote-unquote high
sugar beverages that they want people to
consume less of consuming few added
sugars in the diet is a fairly Universal
recommendation for improved health and
body weight
so what they did was they just made
those red items less convenient by
taking them out of eye level or moving
them away from fridges that were more
convenient so rather than having them
right at the checkout so people can grab
one while they're buying they would move
them to the other side of the store and
they would replace those with water to
make water more convenient and just that
can influence people's purchasing habits
so although that's a very small scale
experiment it's kind of suggestive of
how the overall environment can
subconsciously influence what you buy
but then also what you consume and when
you kind of zoom out
and you think about your life
there'll be multiple instances of this
throughout the day if someone's working
at a desk and their colleague brings in
donuts and they put them on the desk
suddenly you really want donuts you
might not have even been thinking about
Donuts before
if your colleagues said oh by the way
there are donuts in the kitchen
you might carry on working and think I
might get to one later but when you can
see it and when you can smell it and
it's visible you're more inclined to eat
it and in today's environment high
calorie
hyper palatable
um foods are more convenient than ever
what belief that is widely held either
in mainstream Media or amongst most
people with regards to Fat Loss
do you wish that you could get rid of
like what do most people misbelieve
about fat loss and how it works that you
would like to try and dispense with
I think there are I think there are a
couple of big ones
um number one that there is a a best
diet I don't think
people's search for what diet should I
start next is a fruitful question
because it isn't a case of picking keto
or picking intermittent fasting or
picking time restricted feeding or
whatever those are all
those are all vehicles that ultimately
take people to the same destination of a
reduced calorie intake
um I also think that
the more
I I want to kind of wear this delicately
the more intelligent someone tends to be
within the fat loss obesity research
space the less they point the finger at
the individual
so obesity researchers will say
typically yes there is obviously
individual responsibility if you go to
the gym or not no one is going to force
you to do so
but
obesity researchers will say that
obesity rates are going up because of
the interception between genetics
biology and the overall environment and
they don't look at people gaining weight
as a kind of willpower deficiency they
view it as in some ways you need more
willpower now to lose weight than you
would have 20 30 40 50 years ago and to
go back to the kind of rodent example
if you change the foods that you give
rodents no one blames the rodents for
gaining weight it's a natural
consequence to you changing their diet
but on a global level our diets have
been changing because of the powers that
be above us food manufacturers
governments that Implement taxes on say
sugar sweetened beverages for example
governments could influence the food
supply as well food subsidies can
influence the food supply in some ways
we are just Pawns in the bigger game of
chess
I really really like that and I think
the genetics component is so fascinating
I'm going to guess you'll have looked at
the behavioral genetics outcomes that
correlate twin studies parents with
children you know a lot of the time you
may see two overweight parents with an
overweight child it's like seven or
eight years old and they're not super
overweight but you're like you're gonna
be a fat adult I can already see it and
a lot of the time you think oh my God
you know look at this this family
causing this child to eat too much due
to their unhealthy lifestyle and
again you're right you do have to be
delicate here because if everybody was
born on an island that didn't have any
unhealthy food no one would be
overweight everybody would be you know
the the optimal size that they should be
uh so individual agency plays a massive
role in what you can do but just how
much willpower and self uh sovereignty
do we expect from people do you want to
create a world in which it is easier for
people to be healthy or more difficult
for people to be healthy and this is a
conversation again we'll get onto seed
oils and and the quality of water and
phthalates and stuff in a little bit but
that that's something that doesn't
really get spoken about all that much
even going past the quality of food
simply the environment and the
availability of this type of food the
triggers that you see all the time the
chocolate bars next to the the checkout
etc etc but
you see these children I think I'd be
right in saying that body weight
correlates 0.6 to 0.8
between children and biological parents
and it correlates basically zero with
adoptive parents so what I mean by that
is that if you take two identical kids
who have two healthy parents and put
both of them into an overweight parents
household the likelihood is that both of
those children will correlate very
highly with their healthy weight parents
and not at all with their environmental
adoptive parents and the reverse is true
too that you can have
larger parents give birth to twins that
get separated into different adoptive
households that are healthy
that end up being overweight despite
being in this healthy environment Robert
Plowman the number one behavioral
geneticist on the planet is a guy who
says he's uh he has a predisposition to
overeating but he gave me this really
great Insight which is there are many
ways to become fat that you can become
fat because you have overactive ghrelin
response perhaps so your stomach makes
you feel a little bit more hungry or
perhaps you are less prone to enjoying
exercise perhaps your Sleep Quality
tends to just be worse your Baseline for
Sleep Quality tends to be worse perhaps
your Baseline set of Happiness
Downstream from that you comfort eat
because of your perhaps depressive
episodes etc etc all of these can exist
individually or together or can combine
to create some monstrous situation in
which this person very much is swimming
upstream and you know Joker willink and
David Goggins have been on the show and
I'm all for taking personal
responsibility and I want to encourage
people to do that and you know I don't
need to bang that yet again yeah
it is a delicate line to walk to say we
know that genetically things may be more
difficult for you with regards to your
predisposition not biologically you
don't even need to do the I've got a
metabolism and gluten makes me inflamed
it's like your psychology is different
around food the way that you relate to
food is different the protein folding in
your brain literally makes you taste
food in a different way to other people
and on top of that the environment's
changed a lot those are two huge
triggers that can cause Downstream from
that a ton of people's uh
relationships with food to be incredibly
different
firstly
your last five minutes you have talked
about something above and beyond
almost any personal trainer or Fitness
professional I see talking about on
social media why
that's a rhetorical why but
I haven't heard people summarize that
facet of obesity research as eloquently
as you have and it's in some ways it's
kind of worrying because that should be
more mainstream but the number of things
you touched on that brilliant by the way
so as an example let's talk about kind
of biological variants when people if
you say there is a genetic factor or
predisposition to obesity a lot of
people will immediately say you're
talking [__] and their straw man
argument to this is
babies are never born obese
and you will be amazed how many times
I've heard people say that as if it's
just this binary thing it's like well no
that baby wasn't obese so it's there's
no kind of genetic component but that's
not what geneticists will say
geneticists will say that they have
predispositions to certain things so
like you have alluded to there can be
biological predispositions that affect
appetite there can be genetic variants
that make people feel hungrier on
um on an emotional level something that
you touched on for example
if you look at emotional eating studies
if you impose an emotional stimulus on
people you can influence their food
intake immediately so if you make people
watch a sad video clip a subset of
people who are described as emotional
eaters will immediately eat more food
afterwards whereas people who do not
score highly on an emotional eating
questionnaire their food intake kind of
Remains the Same and
if you use that as like one example
one of the
um relationships that has been noted is
obesity and depression are described as
having a bi-directional relationship in
that obesity could increase someone's
risk of depression but depression can
also increase someone's risk of obesity
and most people wouldn't say that
depression is something that falls
solely on personal responsibility
yes people might say if you have
depression maybe you could improve it if
you adopted these habits I know people
will say if you go out inside and go
outside and exercise that might help if
you change your diet maybe that will
help but ultimately most people will
acknowledge that if someone has severe
depression
that isn't quite as easy as just telling
them that telling them that they have to
change their behaviors and it will fix
it it's obviously more complicated than
that but when it comes to obesity and
body weight
people have a tendency to point in the
finger solely at the person and like you
say this isn't
um eliminating individual agency it's
just saying that there are other factors
that influence individual agency and
another one that you touched on which
again is great is say for example sleep
susceptibility
if you look Sleep Quality susceptibility
if you look at sleep studies you can
influence how much food someone eats
just by giving them a reduced sleep
opportunity
so for example if you give
um if you give someone 8.5 hours sleep
opportunity per day or you cut that down
by around half
the next day the people who have slept
less will consume more food
it will skew appetite related hormones
and they tend to feel hungrier
also people that sleep better are will
find it harder to gain lean body mass or
they will be more susceptible to losing
lean body mass than people who sleep for
longer
but there is obviously a biological
interception on how well people sleep
yes there are some things that you can
do yourself but there are also some
biological drivers that can ruin sleep
quality that are very hard for you to
overcome
just on your own there's only so much
that individual behaviors can do to
override that biology and that's the
thing that not many people talk about
and you have just talked about so many
facets of that better than most Fitness
professionals that I know the reason
that it's not fashionable for any
Fitness professionals to talk about it
is that it fundamentally D agencies them
like they are uh cutting the legs out
from underneath an industry that they
need to make money in right if you say
well look Ben uh we're gonna do our best
with you mate uh but you know the best
thing that could have happened would
have actually for you to have had a
different set of parents Who provided
you with a separate genetic Baseline for
you to work from and this is something
I've been an idea that I've been playing
about with a lot recently which is
the um the danger of taking too much
responsibility and the uh backlash that
we are seeing against victimhood culture
so again I've been Mr personal agency
sovereignty like since I began this show
it was the reason I began the show
because I wanted to take control of my
own
desires my own life everything right but
I do understand that this is heavily as
a reaction to a what seems to be
increasingly soft World in which people
will blame their circumstances and
systemic whatever for something which it
isn't the fault of the circumstances or
the system it is because of them and
they are fully in control of the
decisions that they're making and they
choose to make bad decisions over and
over again
however there are many contributing
elements here including your genetic
Baseline including the environment that
you're around including your level of
Education I imagine must be correlated
as well with the weight that you gain or
lose
a lot of these things it's like it's so
hard to thread the needle and it's so
much easier to come out and say if
you're fat it's exclusively your fault
and
again that's not to say that anybody who
is absolutely superbly obese if they
were deposited on a desert island they
would be skinny right they're going to
lose weight so the point isn't that
people can't do these things it's how
difficult is it going to be for them to
do it and there are incentives within
the fitness industry to over blow the
impact that personal agency can have on
weight change uh and again it can be
ultimate it could be 100 you could kill
yourself with dieting but how much
willpower is it going to take and then
there are incentives on the other side
with regards to the food and drinks
industry for them to not necessarily do
this so I think that's a really nice
primer that
hopefully makes people feel uh well not
righteously angry but you know like
there is a battle to be waged here and
that the challenges that you face when
it comes to your fat loss journey and
your uh alterations with regards to your
diet and your training you know if
you're finding it difficult
yeah perhaps quite rightly this isn't
the easiest environment in which to be
healthy oh it's never been easier to get
access to food from so we said well yeah
but it's also never been easy to be fat
so it is very much a set of scales
I think there's something really
interesting that you said there and when
you talk about almost like a reactive uh
a reactive response to victimhood I
think people often fall in kind of very
binary camps where if I talk about
environmental reasons that one person
might find it harder than another
I will get some hatred from people
saying you are removing personal
responsibility and I've never said that
it isn't this binary dichotomous view
where it's black or white
and as an example of this which is maybe
easier for people to understand is
you couldn't take let's say almost
anyone let's not say anyone because then
people will interject with medical
conditions you can take almost anyone on
the planet and you can make them lose
weight
and this is seen reliably in controlled
feeding studies so in the most
aggressive controlled feeding studies
people will lose huge amounts of weight
this has been seen in numerous extreme
circumstances what is that what's a
controlled feeding study you lock
someone in a in a building that's only
got sort of a supply of food yeah I mean
that is literally what it is so you will
have something like a described as a
metabolic Ward and you can precisely
yes correct but you can have living
studies where people will live in a
metabolic Ward for say 50 days and you
can feed them precise amounts of certain
foods to see exactly what happens and
some of these are brutal so for example
there was a meal frequency study which
would have been
I think say 50 years ago now and they
would feed people who would be described
as morbidly obese I don't necessarily
love the categorization but that's how
they would have been described at the
time and they were fed 600 calories per
day via liquid nutrition so it's like
skimmed milk
um I think corn starch some other things
like a not very tasty drink but you can
do that and you will see people lose
ridiculous amounts of weight
and I think people will look at
experiments like that and say see if the
person wants it enough they can do it
because technically they can do it but
what we are saying is that yes someone
can do it there is always personal
responsibility there but it's harder for
one person to get to the Finish Line
than it is for another person some
people will feel like they're swimming
Upstream more than other people so for
me for example
I was always like a very active kid I
wasn't someone that ate a lot of ultra
processed foods I grew up in a really
rural area where
there were almost no convenience Foods I
was over 20 years old when I ever
ordered my first takeaway because food
restaurants couldn't deliver to us so I
grew up with a loving mother who I lived
with all the time who would home cook
everything from fresh I wasn't one of
those kids that grew up sedentary I was
a child I had activity in like installed
on me when I was probably five years old
playing all different kinds of sports
and as most people will probably already
know
it's very easy to continue habits versus
trying to create new ones or trying to
stop old ones and for me I was always an
active kid I was never someone who
grew up loving the taste of ultra
processed foods I was never someone that
scoffed every time I ate a vegetable
even things like vegetable enjoyment
there's a genetic component there and
people know this like coriander some
people it tastes like soap some people
don't there are genetic variants where
brassical vegetables can be really
bitter but other people don't have those
same
um kind of genetic uh
um alterations and just things like this
can make it harder for someone and no
one is really saying that you can't lose
weight under the right conditions if you
lock someone in a room and you take away
all their food they will lose weight
what we're saying is when left of their
own devices it's much harder for that
person to reduce their food intake on
their own okay we've set the landscape
we know the modern environment we've
pissed off everybody that wanted to
blame it on personal responsibility
what are moving on to that person's
responsibility moving on to the toolkit
that people need to understand if they
want to lose body fat what are the
absolute fundamentals that everybody
needs to understand when it comes to Fat
Loss
great question
um firstly I would kick things off by
saying how much you weigh is not a
behavior it is a consequence of some
biological factors and a combination of
behaviors so
fat loss itself can be achieved via
various methods some of them healthy
some of them less healthy and I think it
is easier to break it down to individual
behaviors
going back to the example you used or I
used of you where you're talking about
um
having external rewards if you set a
goal
sometimes the goal isn't always within
your control there are other factors
that influence whether you get there but
if you can break it down to behaviors
it's easier to kind of build those
habits so the most universally agreed
upon recommendations which aren't very
controversial but they're surprisingly
controversial in today's day and age is
reduced calorie intake
consuming adequate protein consuming
enough protein tends to have a mildly
beneficial effect on weight loss or fat
loss it can help retain lean body mass
lean body mass can
raise energy expenditure mildly if
someone's consuming
um if someone's building muscle tissue
reduced energy density diets
are also um a big one so energy density
is calories per gram of food so to use
an easy example if you had an apple here
which is primarily sugar and water no
protein no fat and then you had jelly
beans next to it which is also primarily
sugar
because the concentration of sugar is
much higher in the jelly beans the the
number of jelly beans you would eat for
the same number of calories would be
disgustingly small like 100 calories of
jelly beans would be almost nothing
versus a whole apple and this is an
example of energy density foods that
contain a lot of calories per gram tend
to be easier to over consume and tend to
be worse for appetite regulation which
is one of the many reasons why
prioritizing unprocessed Foods
is an almost universally agreed upon
recommendation for health and body
weight eating things like
meats and fishes and vegetables and
fruits and things that are kind of more
close to their natural state versus
Ultra processed
um
products that are engineered often to be
as tasty as possible often very high in
calories often very hard to stop eating
those are the things that are very
difficult to disagree on is the reason
for that because satiety as in just how
much real estate is taken up in your
stomach is one of the key determinants
in terms of making you feel full
uh yes and this has been tested with a
series of very weird experiments so for
example uh let's say there are two
milkshakes and you have identical
Milkshakes that you aerate one or you
add more water so there's more volume so
exactly the same calories as a
foundation but you put more air into one
or more water to to increase the volume
by lowering the energy density of this
one and having more volume for the same
number of calories this will cause
people to consume fewer calories
afterwards so it is better for appetite
regulation like you say because there is
a certain amount of real estate in the
stomach and if you are eating a higher
volume of food it influences not only
how much you eat at that meal but also
at your subsequent meal so as an example
I mean there are various examples of
this you can aerate you know like cheese
snacks cheese balls cheese okay whatever
if you put more air into those snacks so
it has exactly the same number of
calories but it's bigger people will
consume few of them big balls is what
you're prescribing Ben yeah that is an
example of reduced energy density I mean
but in the real world a more easy way to
implement it would be things like
cooking with less fat if you have a
portion of vegetables and you cook them
with a load of butter
that will increase the energy density
significantly and
almost
super reliably will cause people to
consume more calories without feeling
more full afterwards so reducing the
amount of added fat I'm not saying fat
is bad but if you had potatoes and then
you had deep fried potatoes it is much
easier to consume more of the deep fried
potatoes both from taste perspective and
a calorie perspective you can also do
things like food substitutions so on a
plate if you have beef and rice and
vegetables the vegetables have the
lowest energy density out of all of them
and if you increase the serving of
vegetables relative to the other two
items of food people will consume fewer
calories based off that so you can use
it with food preference like the way you
cook the foods that you're selecting and
the aerated food snacks is like an
extreme example but it's a way of
testing that mechanism of food volume
versus satiety everybody when their
dieting has used those low calorie
popcorns every everyone's gone for them
and you go how the [__] what what Harry
Potter Wizardry has gone on to make this
bag of popcorn 89 calories like how he
looks like the massive bag of popcorn
and it's salted or sweet or whatever uh
charity popcorn in the UK is the one
that I seem to remember eating when I
was getting lean for Ibiza
um have you looked at the science of
orification
so that that is the uh corner of the
food industry that designs the texture
of foods
and I remember reading in an
evolutionary cycle I I'm I have read
some cool I'm not well versed it's just
it was really interesting this eve psych
book that I read and it talked about how
ancestrally novel it would be to have a
food that was both uh soft and fluffy
but also crunchy
so if you think about most foods
naturally that we've spoken about I mean
an apple kind of does have that you know
it's got that kind of crunch to it but
it's got but it's not super fluffy
um it's not a Milky Way or a Snickers
bar uh or specifically fries french
fries you know or an Oreo so what you
have when you actually look and as soon
as you it's like the Matrix once you see
this you can't unsee it in food what
you're looking at not just with regards
to the combination of carbs and fat and
sugar and The Taste profile and the
ability for it to spike that sensation
of sugar and saltiness on the tongue
that would have been very normal
ancestrally but the texture of what
you're eating is unbelievably uh like
super normal in terms of the stimulus so
um
an Oreo two
crunchy bits of biscuit with something
sort of soft and lubricating in the
middle of french fries is exactly the
same it's so
when you actually look at it as a what
is the sort of thing that goes on in my
mouth from a texture perspective when I
bite into this it is unbelievably novel
and if you go to say okay please try and
replicate this in something that would
have been regularly available
ancestrally your liver doesn't feel like
that and berries aren't really like that
and apples and roots and and Tube tubers
and stuff none of these things I like
that uh so yeah that's just a another
thing to layer on top that I I always
like to think about no one ever
considers the texture the attractive
texture of foods so there's a there's
like a slightly different angle on
texture as well so as you as you have
rightly explained
um food manufacturers will engineer
foods to have a certain reward value
that we can't access elsewhere so
typically in nature you will find things
that are high in sugar such as fruit or
higher in Sugar you will find things
that are high in protein and fat like
fish and meat but it's very rare that
you will find things that are both high
in sugar and and high in fat which is
what things like ice cream and
cheesecake chocolate and cheesecake all
of those tend to have this combination
that you don't really find in nature and
texture can also influence appetite so
um there was one experiment where they
took
um they took food like I think it was
beef and potatoes and vegetables and
they they mashed it and cut it into
smaller parts
to make it easier to consume and what
they found was that because it was
faster to consume
people naturally ate more food so there
is the simplified version is when you
start your meal there is perhaps a
certain amount of time before your
appetite signals kick in and say you
know what I've probably had enough food
So the faster you can consume food
within that if you watch anyone that's
in like an eating contest they will tend
to eat quick to try and race against
those signals and if you modify the
texture of foods to make it easier to
consume quickly people tend to consume
more that the extreme example of that is
if you have a very high calorie
milkshake and you're drinking it with a
straw you can consume sugar faster than
you would tend to when you're chewing it
uh have you seen the ice cream
competitive eating competitions have you
seen what they eat to help them eat more
ice cream
no they've got a bucket of french fries
next to them so if you're in an ice
cream eating competition you'll the guys
will go down and grab a handful of salty
french fries and conversely you would
think I want every Square centim cubic
centimeter of my stomach real estate to
be used for the ice cream what's the
theory that
um one of the main reasons that you are
struggling to eat more ice cream as a
competitive eater brain freeze apart
from the brain freeze actually how the
[__] do they get around that that's when
you said fries I thought you meant like
something hot to try it they've got a
little hat on they've got a heated one
of those heated hats uh no it's it's to
do with uh I think again mixing up this
texture that's going into the mouth
which must make uh more ice cream eating
less disgusting to them but it's just
hilarious to see a competitive ice cream
eating competition and then someone yeah
exactly dunk in and eat fries have you
have you ever heard of the term sensory
specific satiety which is what you've
already been discussing I just don't
know so sensory specific satiety is
um simplified it's almost like you get
bored of the same thing basically and
you also talk about it with taste so for
example if you feed someone sandwiches
and they have one filling
or you feed someone else sandwiches with
multiple fillings
the person who served multiple fillings
will consume more food and the idea is
you can get bored of consuming the same
thing and the the easiest example of
this in everyday life perhaps is if you
went to a food buffet
if I served you your regular dinner on
its own a la carte you eat it if you go
to a food buffet and that first plate is
your regular dinner you don't stop
afterwards because you see all of these
very tasty foods and you see all of that
I want to try a bit of that I want to
try a bit of that and it
there is supposedly a possible kind of
evolutionary basis for this in that in
times of food scarcity
if you found another type of food it is
beneficial for you to keep eating
because you you now have more food than
you are used to and supposedly it's
almost like overriding your
um typical appetite signals because you
have multiple sources of food this is a
good time for you to consume more so if
you've hunted a an animal and you've
eaten it but then you find another
source of food you could eat that now
and the theory behind sensory specific
satiety is you will get bored of a
certain taste or Texture but if you that
is complemented with a different taste
or Texture french fries it's easier for
you to keep eating so for example if you
had a bowl of french fries or you had a
bowl of french fries and ice cream
it is sometimes easier to keep going or
even things like if you have french
fries but then you have
um ketchup or sauce or something on the
side it's often easier to keep going
because you don't get bored of that same
thing
okay so important things to know
calories you've said that calories
matter but I said I saw Dr Giles yo and
he said that great guy by the way
calories tell you absolutely nothing is
that right
um so giledio uh professor of genetics
at Cambridge I think he's he's an
incredible guy and I think he got some
backlash on social media recently in my
opinion without casting too much shade I
think people threw shade at him without
realizing who he is because the way
people talk to him like who's this guy
that doesn't know what he's talking
about is like dude with a stellar
academic career for decades and decades
very very much chill the [__] out pause
research and then come back so jalzio
he's a fantastic guy and I actually
listened to his podcast in full his
recent one and I feel like the video
that went on social media and what he
said in the podcast didn't match but it
was a hell of a trailer and I understand
why it riled people up so
what Giles yo will say like the
simplified version then this is echoed
with with other people who are also some
of which are very intelligent is
calories matter yes
but
there are limitations within that so for
example it is very difficult to
accurately quantify how many calories
you're consuming it doesn't matter how
meticulous someone is with calorie
counting
calorie counting is
impossible nearly impossible to get
perfectly accurately and often that's
for reasons outside of your control
labels the nutritional information is
allowed a natural variance so just
because something says it's 100 calories
doesn't mean it's 100 it might be 110 it
might be 90.
um also the way you prepare food for
example can change the calorie content
of that food or the energy content of
that food just like if you juice
vegetables you can remove fiber you may
put the vegetables in and then you juice
it but if it removes the fiber you have
changed the qualities of that food even
though the food itself is the same so
the way you prepare food can influence
the calorie values of that food but one
of the things that he
um has explained which is really
important is that caloric availability
of food or something referred to
um as metabolizable energy of that food
so for example say nuts if you have 100
grams of nuts
or say 100 calories of nuts when you
consume them
some of those nuts will go through you
if you checked in the toilet afterwards
you would probably see fragments of nuts
so you have not absorbed all of the
calorie content from those nuts now if
you break the nuts down so they're
easier to digest by making them into
peanut butter
so let's say you have peanuts peanut
butter or even peanut oil which is
obviously refined right now and it's
changed the food Matrix completely the
caloric availability goes up so you will
con you will absorb and utilize a higher
percentage of those calories so just
because you're consuming 100 calories on
paper doesn't mean that the end result
is the same and I think that's one of
the big things that trips people up
because you have people that keep saying
all calories are the same
and then you have other people that go
well actually no because we know that
calories certain foods can behave
differently in the body we know that the
calories you eat from foods are isn't
necessarily the same as the number of
calories you absorb from food and you
almost get two camps arguing past each
other
so
in a general like mixed diet let's not
use outlier examples of sweet corn or
nuts or how you blend vegetables or
whatever if you take a mixed diet
and you change the quantity of that
mixed diet so you're consuming more
calories or fewer calories
that can predict body weight gain or
body weight reduction but when you
compare calorie values between Foods
things get a little bit more complicated
because foods that are higher in fiber
can decrease the metabolizable energy
value of that food foods that are higher
in protein your body will burn a little
bit more energy digesting those Foods so
what Giles is saying is calories matter
but they don't tell you the about food
quality which is important
um people can focus so much on calories
that they Overlook the kind of Health
aspect of food
dude well in back in
2010 2011 when If It Fits your Macros
first came out and car back loading
great example by the way keep going yeah
the uh and Skip loading did you ever do
skip loading no what's that skip loading
was like carb night but it was on a
Sunday and the only goal each Sunday so
you went completely carb free you went
like keto slash carb free throughout the
week and then on a Sunday the goal was
to eat as many carbs as possible
disregard everything else so the advice
was to eat an entire box of children's
cereal upon waking and this was it's
offsetting the metabolism going through
the floor and you know the date you had
to track the day that your body weight
went back to the Baseline that it was on
the Saturday and this was also used by
competitive bodybuilders to see where
they were at with a different name okay
cool nice it was rebranded
um but so when you've got especially If
It Fits your Macros my guys from propane
Fitness one of their most viewed videos
is uh we got a six pack we got a
six-pack eating Haribo and cheesecake
and you know what you're doing is you're
sticking a middle finger up at Food
quality at satiety at all of these
things and personally for me I actually
think I timed it quite badly because a
lot of what I learned what some of the
inherited wisdom that I learned during a
very formative period of me starting to
understand dieting was the If It Fits
your Macros phase and the problem that I
had there was I I really didn't think
about food quality all that much I
didn't think about satiety I didn't
think about energy density I didn't
think about
where has this come from what has this
been washed in could I why am I not
buying for an extra 70 Pence why am I
not buying a kilo of organic chicken
breast instead of a kilo of
God knows where they're from chicken
breasts not that those are bad but my
point being that I disregarded
exclusively anything which wasn't kaiko
it's like look if it's not calories
I don't care bro and I got lean and I
was like whatever 23 or something so I
was made out of rubber and Magic so it
didn't really matter
um but
yeah I I feel like
um this sort of insight the kind of
insights that you're putting across here
although they're a lot less sexy sorry
but yeah no they are Unfortunately they
I think should set somebody up for a
much better
long-term relationship with food which
is significantly more sustainable yeah
so
you're kind of If It Fits your Macros
example I think is a really good extreme
end of the spectrum to why someone like
geldio will say calories don't matter
they're not the be-all and end-all so
traditionally in bodybuilding culture
people used to diet on a very
restrictive list of foods
um there are top bodybuilders that will
say they only ate five foods for 16
weeks going into their show and it's
like chicken breasts sweet potatoes oats
um rice and vegetables or whatever so
people were dieting on very restrictive
lists of foods and If It Fits your
Macros spawned from the idea of food
substitution so on bodybuilding forums
if someone said hey
I'm supposed to eat rice but can I eat
potatoes instead they would say sure If
It Fits your Macros that's fine and the
idea was that you can interchange foods
with similar properties if your meal
plan says chicken you are allowed to eat
fish if you want you are allowed to eat
turkey if you want that's how like
neurotic and obsessive bodybuilding
that's used to be
and then If It Fits your Macros kind of
spiral to the point where people were
saying
food quality doesn't matter as long as
you are consuming the same number of
calories and whilst technically it's
it's kind of true in some ways if you
ate nothing but Ultra processed junk
food and you consumed it within a
calorie deficit you would lose body fat
and body weight which you already know
but it's not saying that all the other
properties of food aren't important so
you can have two diets that are two
thousand calories but if this one is
more nutrient dense it is less processed
it has a lower energy density it is
higher protein it is higher fiber
although they start as 2 000 calories
each the end result in their body is is
starkly different what's the difference
in their bodies going to be
okay so um from an energy density
perspective appetite regulation would be
superior on the unprocessed diet
if a diet is higher in fiber it reduces
the metabolizable energy within that
diet so basically higher fiber diets you
excrete a little bit more energy than
you will on a lower fiber diet
higher protein diets you will burn more
energy digesting
that because protein has a higher energy
cost of utilization something called the
thermic effect of food
or diet-induced thermogenesis
um
where else have I got to protein fiber
food quality appetite health for example
Ultra processed foods I know Health like
very unsexy topic Ultra processed foods
the higher percentage of your diet that
comes from Ultra processed foods there
is a link with an increased risk of
various non-communicable diseases and
all cause mortality
and it's not necessarily saying that
it's purely from the ultra processed
foods it might be that unprocessed foods
are being displaced out of your diet
so if two people are consuming 2 000
calories but one of them is consuming a
lot of vegetables and the other one is
consuming a lot of jelly beans obviously
the health effect of the diet is
different it's not that the jelly beans
contain some carcinogen it's that the
replacement of
some other food that would have been
neuroprotective physiologically
protective etc etc possibly so yeah it
could be that the beneficial compounds
that are found in diverse unprocessed
nutrient-dense diets are removed when
consuming a diet that's high in Ultra
processed foods that are nutrient Spas
it is possible that certain foods are
more fattening than others for various
reasons
um but it's very hard to isolate those
without looking at very long-term
studies it gets it's very difficult to
say is this one compound additive e
number that we use in this donut going
to cause people to gain more weight over
the next 20 years it's not a study that
you tend to engineer but generally
speaking diets that are high in Ultra
processed foods are worse for health
obviously so although the two diets are
the same the actual health impact and
the body composition impact can be
different despite the same number of
calories when 30 ingested okay someone's
listening to this and they say I
understand that the environment that
we're in is more difficult now to lose
weight I understand that I have genetic
predispositions and biological set
points that are different to other
people I also understand that there are
some principles that I need to look at
when I'm designing a diet yeah
what do I do
Ben there's all of these different diets
out here there's intermittent fasting
time restricted eating keto Carnival
veganism
is it your suggestion that you should
find the diet which allows you to remain
in a calorie deficit with as many whole
unprocessed Foods as possible
sustainably for as long as possible
whilst feeling good about yourself is
that the rough heuristic
done completed it like it's a great
explanation
um so the the kind of slightly more
long-winded explanation for anyone
that's curious is dietary trials that
look at Weight Loss interventions tend
to be short so for example low carb
versus low-fat which is better for fat
loss one group consumes a low carb diet
the other group consumes a low-fat diet
for six months and they might notice
that the low carb group lost a little
bit more body weight at the end or a
little bit more fat at the end but when
you extend these trials for longer
periods of time most of the differences
wash away and they wash away for
biological reasons that make weight loss
harder in the long term but also
adherence tends to decrease over time so
if someone watching this is like you
know what my friend got great results on
keto so I'm going to try keto But
ultimately unless someone can stick to
keto for X number of months slash years
it's almost knowing that you're going to
get into a yo-yo cycle of I'm doing keto
now oh no keto has sapped my will to
live I'm going to stop doing it [__]
hate keto I tried it I tried it and it
just I I'm so hungry my stomach doesn't
enjoy it
I can't do it and and this is a perfect
example because some people watching
this will be like I love keto when I am
on a keto diet I find my appetite is way
better my Hunger levels are down my
mental Clarity is improved I feel better
and whether that's keto or low carb
which are kind of under the same
umbrella
when you look at long-term trials most
the differences between named diets wash
away there is no best weight loss diet
anyone that's telling you there's the
best weight loss diet normally has
something to sell you but when you look
at what's described as the
inter-individual data some people get
better results than others so just
because diet X might not be better than
diet y on paper it doesn't mean that one
person gets better results on that x one
person out there loves keto someone else
out there like yourself hates keto and
it's important to
um be aware of those because some people
will find that their appetite is better
on diet X or they feel better on diet X
and if that allows them to adhere to a
calorie deficit for an extended period
of time then that's important are you
saying that adherence or dietary
compliance is the biggest lever or the
most important factor when it comes to
weight loss 100 100
so diets are more important than
exercise for Pure weight loss in general
um for multiple reasons but X is very
difficult for exercise to Trump the
importance of dietary changes why
um
multiple reasons number one it's quite
hard to burn a lot of energy purely to
exercise so you do CrossFit which means
that you work harder than your average
person and let's say you burned just for
round figures 500 calories per workout
which is again above the average for
most people's gym program if you did
that four times per week which is again
above the average of most gym programs
that's 2 000 calories but in the grand
scheme of it across the week it's not a
huge amount of energy when you think
someone like yourself let's say you were
burning 3000 calories per day that's 21
000 calories over the course of the week
so it's it's kind of like the icing on
top on top of that exercise routines
um tend to make people feel hungrier
some people feel hungrier not
universally but if you get a hundred
people to start running and you don't
tell them what to do with their diet
some of them will lose a lot of weight
but some of them will not only not lose
weight but they will gain weight and
some people will say for example there
are people out there who start training
for a marathon and by the end of it
they've gained weight and it's a
biological response to the increase in
exercise volume where they suddenly feel
hungrier we should interject there that
that's not necessarily bad weight though
you know someone starts going to the gym
and they start doing a push-pull leg
split and they gain weight well I mean
that that's what you were hoping for
presumably this isn't people training
for weight loss this is people training
for performance yeah so uh weight is an
easier metric to measure and because
getting accurate body composition
um measurements is is difficult when
you're looking at kind of population
studies but if you look at aerobic
training interventions for weight loss
rather than bringing in resistance
training which which tends to increase
lean body mass as you rightly pointed
out even aerobic training into that
tensions which are supposedly the best
interventions for weight loss some
people when they exercise their weight
will stay stagnant despite the fact
they've increased their exercise volume
and some people's appetite ratings their
subjective appetite ratings go up so
let's say your typical person wants to
lose weight so they start going to the
gym for the first time ever
they go three times a week they burn two
or three hundred calories while they're
there but what they don't necessarily
realize is when they leave the gym they
feel a little bit hungrier than they
were before they went it so without
realizing it they can slowly creep up
their calorie intake and the weight loss
effects of exercise interventions in
isolation
are underwhelming which is why dietary
interventions need to be paired
what would you say to the people that
are
listening to this and say
well [__] why do I even need to bother
to train I evidently don't need to
exercise if I want to lose weight I can
just lose weight on the couch yeah so
the the kind of important the important
thing to point out is technically that
is correct you can of course I mean you
can lose weight by smoking more
cigarettes and doing methamphetamine and
cocaine and Ibiza if you want and that
is why I say how much you weigh is not a
behavior because just because someone
weighs less doesn't mean that their
health is equally improved regardless of
the vehicle that took them there so we
know that Health we know that the health
benefits of exercise are profound and
diverse so
people who are more sedentary there are
associations with increased risk of
non-communical non-communicable diseases
and all cause mortality and people who
exercise more there is a decrease of
non-communicable disease risk and all
cause mortality so whether exercise
helps you lose weight or not is it's
almost looking at exercise at the thing
that that's not its main job so yeah
that's a very good way to put it the
only the the sole goal of exercise is
not to help you lose weight it's a
byproduct that it can help you with
exactly and like you said if someone
started doing CrossFit like something
that you have done just because the the
number on the scale changes firstly
doesn't mean that your body composition
hasn't changed you may lose body fat and
gain lean body mass and your weight
might remain static
um but perhaps more importantly it
doesn't necessarily mean your health
hasn't changed and this has actually
been seen in a few research papers where
people's attitudes towards exercise
there a lot of people's main motivation
to exercise is to lose weight
and when they're not losing weight their
external reward has been removed and
they no longer know how to judge the
effectiveness of their exercise training
regime so when they go into the gym with
the goal of losing weight at some point
they will hit a weight Plateau which is
inevitable because if you lost weight
forever you would die which is
sub-optimal
and when you hit that weight plateau
they're like well what's the point
and it's because they're only in their
head their only way of judging how
effective their exercise program is is
the number on the scale and that is a
problem because unless they have other
metrics to judge your Effectiveness by
or like you said earlier enjoyment that
makes you want to go to the gym in the
first place as soon as the number on the
scale stops moving what's the point
okay so to recap yeah the best diet is
the one that you can adhere to the most
for weight loss correct for weight loss
the principles that you need to be
looking at are that calories do matter
an awful lot and that they are the
fundamental thermodynamics that underpin
what's going on
that you should be prioritizing uh
protein intake
that you should be aiming for whole
foods that are as satiety inducing as
you can and as uh what's the opposite of
energy dense
uh
low in energy density yeah energy
density is almost a spectrum it's like
high or low energy density right okay
the low in energy density yeah you can
trial through a number of different
diets you find one that both tastes good
and feels good and that you think that
you can stick to yeah adherence now it
seems comes down to a number of things
but one of the key levers will be
willpower
how can people improve their willpower
when it comes to dieting
that is a hell of a question
and I don't have any firm answers for
that
you're the Science Guy Ben come on
science us
I personally so the thing with willpower
is
I feel like
I feel like it it does that thing where
it points the finger at the person which
is is fine to a degree but I think that
there are factors that influence
willpower that people aren't necessarily
aware of like candles
yeah like conscientiousness is massively
math and industriousness both massively
heritable genetics and environment for
example so like uh as an example of that
and it's an extreme it's it's an extreme
example that most people won't try and
refute it uh if your only gym was 30
minutes away from you
and you had to go there on your lunch
break and you had to jump in the car
drive 30 minutes away or you had a gym
that was literally within your office
most people would train more when the
gym is more accessible to them and
although you can say well going to the
gym is just about willpower
it takes far less willpower to over ride
the I don't fancy working out today when
the gym is literally right there and I
say that as someone who has a garage gym
it is far easier for me to to make that
kind of conscious willpower decision to
exercise when I can be in and out in 30
minutes without having to jump in the
car and get changed and shower at the
gym etc etc
um
ah
I don't know I don't have an answer for
how someone can unlock more willpower to
make their weight loss Journey easier
well what you've identified there is the
environment is a key cue and given the
fact that a lot of the people that are
listening to this will have a they're
not at Guantanamo I don't think this is
being piped through the speakers there
although it might be and
given that there are ways that you can
set up your environment that will
engender
that is where I look at things so when
you say how can someone kind of increase
their willpower for it that is actually
how I would answer it so
um if you can if you can make the hard
decisions easier
I don't think that's necessarily A
willpower perspective as such but if you
can engineer your environment to make it
easier
that is where I would focus my intent my
attention so as one kind of example of
this
if I put a donut right in front of the
person listening and say Don't eat this
donut
assuming they like donuts they will have
to
kind of recruit some willpower to
override their natural inclination to
eat the donuts
but when the Donut's not there it
doesn't require the same amount of
willpower so it's not necessarily about
how can people recruit more willpower
it's about how to make their Journey
easier to engage in the behaviors that
will take them to the goal and that is
how I would approach things so
um as an example of this
going back to kind of individual
adherence
what factors and this can be an open
question what factors will make someone
more inclined to exercise that don't
just depend on Willpower
let's say for a moment that you can
never influence someone's genetic level
of willpower
you can still influence how easy it is
for them to exercise
what factors could you change so the
listeners to this podcast will say oh I
could do that
I would say uh making the gym uh or
choosing a gym which is not only one
that you enjoy but one which is very
convenient for you to get to in between
your commute to and from work the gym
that I trained at in gosforth in
Newcastle for a very long time I had to
drive past on my way home so it made me
feel like an extra piece of [__] if I
didn't go in because I was already going
past other things like the ease of
parking uh removing extra steps from
going to the gym if you've got to pay uh
a dollar or a pound every time that you
need to park up outside there's always
going to be something there that's like
oh I don't want to pay that pound today
and it's just justification so finding
something that's nice and frictionless
like that something which has got in
terms of training good open times if you
are looking to move to a different
apartment the place that I'm staying now
I'm right next to a park in Austin which
means I have a 12 minute 45 second Loop
I've timed it an awful lot uh that I can
do and that means that for me getting 10
000 steps in a day is Super for easy
because the second that my phone rings
whether it's a prank call or someone
that I need to speak to immediately my
trainers are on I'm out of the door
trainers at the back door or flip-flops
at the back door and just going for
little walks here and there leaving
Mobility resistance bands and
kettlebells just strewn around the house
I find is great because if I'm just
bored and I'm waiting for the state to
finish cooking or whatever I'll just
pick a kettlebell up five times or I'll
do some overhead presses with a a
resistance band that's another thing
when it comes to diet for me I remember
seeing and this will be in your
wheelhouse
uh people who bought a fruit bowl for
the house had massive increases in the
amount of consumption of fruit
you've got this beautiful display of all
of this stuff that you know that you
should be eating more of and that you're
not eating enough of yeah
buy a fruit bowl don't have
confectionery I have none of the foods
that you ever want to eat anywhere
within Arm's Reach put them in a pantry
put them in a really awkward cupboards
to get to ideally don't have them in the
house at all you know you can't eat the
foods that aren't there uh those would
be
some environment design things I think
these are I think these are really good
examples of how it isn't necessarily
about a willpower deficiency that's why
I said I don't know how someone would
increase their willpower because I think
often it's not necessarily about
willpower it's about changing the
decisions so they require less willpower
in the first place so as an example of
that when I was traveling a lot I uh at
one point I was staying in London and
it's very easy to look at a different
person and say that person's lazy but
when you look at individual
circumstances it's harder to do that so
I train a lot I do some form of exercise
every day even if it's small and I went
to this apartment in London and I did my
work this was on a Sunday and I walked
to the nearest gym which at the time was
10 minutes away and what I didn't
realize is that gym shut at 4pm I think
on a Sunday and I was like [__] where do
I go the next gym was I think a mile and
a half away so immediately for me to
train at that specific time of that
specific day which for a lot of people
is maybe when they finish work
if their gym shuts at 8pm and they can
only go to the gym after 8 PM if they
have to drive further to get to that gym
it's harder to do on top of that the gym
that I went to was expensive
I when I got there for a guest pass I
had to pay 10 pounds but I their monthly
membership I was like a lot of people
just couldn't afford this and for me to
get that I had to jump on the tube to
get there or I would have to walk so
it's either more time effort it's more
kind of um it requires more time or it
requires more expense to get the same
result so for me I personally Love
convenience I love the idea that if
someone is struggling to get to the gym
can you make exercise or physical
activity more convenient so an example
that I know you'll love uh pickleball
great game fantastic best spot in the
world yep me and my wife have just moved
we moved like a year ago and in our
neighborhood there are communal tennis
courts that are free for us to go on and
they have pickleball there I have never
played a sport on a court
for the last probably like 20 years not
tennis I used to play badminton but
since we moved here because that court
is three minutes to walk to
we're playing pickleball multiple times
per week and we would never have done
that before because if you said oh
John's go and play tennis or John's
gonna play Pickleball we're like okay
where's the nearest court 20 minutes
away you know what can't be bothered
yeah it's going to be two hours by the
time we go there for an hour and then
come back and find parking weather so
this is how I prefer to engineer things
where you look at ways to make the hard
easier so going back to food proximity
studies is not necessarily will you'll
rely on Willpower to make small
conscious decisions of I am not going to
eat that Donut for example but you can
decrease the amount of willpower
required to do that if healthier food is
more convenient for you hence the fruit
bowl example if I came to your house and
emptied it from Ultra processed foods
and I made the fruit bowl look Exquisite
the tastiest fruit you've ever looked
even to people that don't like fruit all
of a sudden you're like
yeah I could have one of those exotic
papayas why not yeah uh have you do you
wear a Tracker do you wear a whoop or
anything similar uh no I wear an Apple
Watch but do you wear it during
pickleball
uh yes but I never look at the stats
dude if you get it depends if you're
playing doubles or singles but if you
get a good hard game a competitive game
of singles in for about 90 minutes uh
it's two hours is like the real sweet
spot for me I average a thousand
calories in two hours it's [__]
insane so
I actually use this as an example
um I and traditionally I've never played
tennis I used to play badminton so if
you told me to play tennis I'd be [__]
at it and I would go on the court I
would keep hitting it out and I'd be
like oh you know what I'm probably not
enjoying this the fact that pickleball
is easier it's like a mini tennis to
anyone who doesn't know it because it
was easier it was easier for me to play
with a couple of friends even if they've
never played before and it was a more
accessible version for the beginner that
doesn't know what they're doing but
because it was more accessible I enjoyed
it more from day one so rather than
trying to pick a complicated sport and
being like you know what I suck at this
we went in and we're like God that's
really fun and I am someone who is
admittedly not someone who tends to love
traditional cardio if you said if we
were doing this podcast in person and
you said you know what let's go for an
hour jog afterwards
I can't think of
fewer ways I would rather spend my time
but if you said do you want to go and
play Pickleball I would still jog for an
hour I would run for an hour doing these
prints on the club yeah faster yeah yeah
because I enjoy it yeah time would pass
so it's not necessarily about I need
more willpower to go running I need
better decisions to decrease my need for
willpower a better incentive around that
yeah I mean dude the
secret cardio that it sneaks in is and
the difference between uh monostructural
work you know sitting on a bike uh
sitting on a rower doing skier or
whatever and playing a game that you're
not focused on the discomfort of the
cardio you're focused on the game that
you're playing and trying to win and
distracted by high-fiving your teammate
and [__] talking the opposition and
stuff one thing that I would say I've
spoken about this on the podcast before
I bought a bike desk so it's a recumbent
cycling desk find another one yep and uh
this thing has been an absolute game
changer for me getting zone two in so
zone two is something that I made myself
a promise at the beginning of the year
that I would stick to I wanted to
increase my HRV I wanted to decrease my
resting heart rate I wanted to decrease
my breath rate and I just heard a lot an
awful lot from you know your Brian
McKenzie's of the world and your
hubermans of the world about 180 minutes
of zone two a week would be really good
for you if you could get it in but if
you actually realize what zone two is
it's the shittest of the heart rates
because it's quicker than a walk but for
me it's slower than a run so I'm like
okay well how am I going to find myself
at zone two and then if I do do it I'm
going to be sat on a bike in Gold's Gym
South Central Austin
hating myself hating hating every second
of it whereas now I can sit and do all
of the emails that I didn't really want
to do in any case whilst doing the zone
two that I didn't really want to do in
any case put some good music on and both
of those things have made each other a
lot more enjoyable like I get to do
emails but if I if I do the emails I can
you know get a good bit of training in
and that's going to make me feel good
after and it's a bit of a treat for me
because I can get to put my music on and
that's that's my that's my hack that's
my zone two hack I love this and I love
that you're you're yours is a perfect
example of if I came to you as a
personal Creator let's say I'm one of
those cliche wanky personal trainers and
I said you need to do more zone two
trading as an example and you said
I don't really enjoy it and I'm like you
need more willpower you're lazy you need
to suck it up that is what a lot of
personal trainers would do when they
approach your problem they'll say go to
the gym go for a jog
sit on the bike in the gym and you're
like but I [__] hate that whereas
you're looking at it from the
perspective of how can I make that more
convenient so you buy a recumbent desk
bike and use that and my wife did
something similar where she bought one
of those treadmill desks and she has to
walk at admittedly a pretty slow pace
without distracting her emails because
yeah while you're typing is difficult
but because she works from home on her
laptop and has a remote
a career
she realized that on on a bad day
she would walk uh about 600 steps
because she's just on her laptop from
the morning till the evening she would
get up for lunch and she stays in the
house but then she got a treadmill desk
and suddenly she is walking a lot
but it doesn't feel like effort because
she's doing it in her own environment
she's not having to drive to the gym
she's not having to stand on the
treadmill surrounded by people that she
doesn't necessarily like it's not an
inconvenient time of the day she's not
having to find a place to park it's
reducing the need for willpower by doing
that and it's important to point out
that in both of these instances
it's
it does it has cost money there has been
an investment into that like her
treadmill desk is more expensive than a
lot of people would be able to afford
and I'm not kind of dismissing that but
this is just an example of how
when faced with a difficult decision
telling someone just to do it perhaps
isn't quite as effective as finding
different solutions that take that
person from A to B
yeah I mean my bike desk is 350 bucks
and I think you can get it in the UK for
about 300 pounds it's called in
exerpeutic extra work 2.0 with Bluetooth
that's the one that you're actually
after that sounds like a that sounds
like a bike named for a man oh it's a
it's a real it's a real [__] piece of
kit uh final thing what have we not
spoken about so far with regards to the
world of eating with regards to personal
impacts of eating and with regards to
the uh fundamentals that people need to
understand
I think that on the whole we have
discussed the most important
fundamentals that
um people would need to adopt I think
breaking weight loss goals down into
into individual habits is important
focusing on the things that are more
within your control such as the type of
exercise you're doing how much physical
activity you're doing what foods you are
consuming these are all kind of
individual habits that are easier to
isolate and focus on and check off
versus I want to lose X number of
kilograms
um from a fundamentals perspective I
would say you have been an incredible
host and I wouldn't say there's anything
that we really needed sandwich in the in
here there are lots of other side
conversations that we could have we
could talk about body image or muscle
growth or other tenets of fat loss but I
think the questions that you've asked
and the conversations that you've put
forward I would say you've done an
incredible job if I've got your seal of
approval that's good enough for me why
should people go if they want to check
out the book and everything else that
you do uh finding me on social media is
fine I'm on Instagram Tick Tock Etc
under the handles BDC Carpenter
dude I appreciate you thank you thank
you very much for having me on thank you
for everyone listening what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
so then press here for a selection of
the best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
foreign
[Music]